conflict between Iran and Israel
dramatically escalated overnight Israel
fired dozens of missiles at Iranian
sites in Syria Syrian military claims
the attack killed 3 and damaged several
air defense sites it was launched after
Iranian forces fired on Israeli army
bases in the Golan Heights this is the
most serious military confrontation ever
between Israel and Iran Seth Doane is in
Jerusalem with more on the story south
good morning good morning this is
potentially a game-changer Israel says
that for the first time ever Iran
directly targeted its military positions
firing 20 missiles from bases inside
Syria Israel claims none of those
missiles made it into their territory
four were intercepted by the Iron Dome
surface-to-air missile system they've
been strengthening to fend off such an
attack Israel retaliated firing missiles
at dozens of Iranian military targets
inside Syria an animation from the
Israeli military shows what it claims
was an attack on a missile launcher
nighttime images released by the Syrian
government allegedly show Syrian air
defenses at work today the Defense
Minister here said Israel will not allow
Iran to use Syria as a frontline base
while Israel has said it doesn't want to
see an escalation the Defense Minister
here said that they would retaliate if
necessary adding if we get rain they'll
get a flood Nora
alright Seth Doane in Jerusalem thank
you